time to check out Chris Hemsworth in
green zone go Google that one alright I
said he i'ma do it in your Australian
accent it's on to check out Chris
Hemsworth in green zone got Google at
one alright because of where the movie
takes place why'd you say it in your
best Bangladesh accent trailer instantly
won me over completely
[Music]
great shot yeah great yeah that hit
Harbor
he's learning to care whoa damn the
stomach awesome man
sometimes and the camera never will
leave that are writing yeah seriously
bone-crunching drives though it's a
pretty cool trailer for the most part
actually I mean yes is a lot of it a
cliche 100% this character is a cliche
the plot in a lot of ways is a cliche
ply but I think what is the thing that
people will be gravitated towards myself
included is the type of visceral gut
punching intensity the way it's captured
the immediacy the moments are the things
that I think people will ultimately be
tuning in for regardless and of course
the charismatic charms of that of a
Chris Hemsworth it's nice to see him a
rocking his Australian accent yeah be
doing a serious role which will probably
have a little bit of that repressed
badass sarcasm from time to time but I
don't see it being like a funny
character per se I'm excited for that
part and then also I think Netflix is
aiming to try to find an audience around
Asia India culture probably the step in
that direction I'm not my brother
I don't know who most of these people
are all right yeah I don't but I bet
that a few of them maybe a couple maybe
one I'm not sure but some of them are
actually predominantly working actors
over in India to say the least that's a
great way to start segwaying audiences
over there at one part of you wants to
say white Savior well that's how we get
it accessible to America you've got to
be able to see ourselves in you got
Chris Hemsworth here and you got David
Harbour here but everyone else does not
look white yeah I think the the action
looks really cool and the I love just
how busy levar ething feels and how
kinetic everything looks and it seems to
have this great blend of handheld action
but you can still tell what's going on
yeah
and I feel like you they'll be mixing
that grid up a little bit of Paul
Greengrass but with something smoother
in the war field and you know now it's
just a question of like will the scenes
in between the action be just as good as
the action moments because this doesn't
read to me as something that you can get
away with just being like cool schlock
it's not like the subject matter no
definitely not it seems like they're
going for something that has deeper
gritty or undertones throughout
obviously I guess I just where my
question my eyebrows are a little bit
raised at but for the most part I feel
like it's probably gonna be a pretty
cool movie yeah yeah what hope I mean
like I said this is probably the most
like mmm like bone-crunching trailer
I've seen in a minute and it kind of
reminded me almost of not necessarily
that it looks as good as the raid but it
kind of reminded me of that in the way
that it's a very straightforward
familiar plotline but just with this
really really strong energetic action
style props to the stunts I'm glad that
Netflix seems to be throwing down on
these types of projects for Chris
Hemsworth I think this will be cool I
that I'm always worried about this kind
of movie because it seems like they come
and they don't necessarily make the
hugest splash however Netflix has been
seeing a lot of success with these
movies just generally they're straight
to Netflix action errs that you know
have all the spectacle that you want
from a big theater version well so
there's a particular quarantine
situation kind of happening worldwide
and this looks like the most exciting
blockbuster level literal film coming
out in the next couple weeks so yeah yes
so I imagine this movie will be a cool
worldwide hit on the streaming platform
I'm looking forward to seeing it trend
as number one in the world
yeah well I'm - I mean I'm curious about
how this will bridge that gap towards
you know more Indian and Asian audiences
and whatnot because you know I'm always
wondering when they set some kind of
crime story there and it's all kind of
in the seedy underbelly of that world
and like we got a lot of flack for not
like a revenue 5 which doesn't have the
exact same plot as this but has certain
similarities to it and that movie has a
very watery set of characters and stuff
so all I guess I would hope
this movie takes its situation and finds
a way to nuance it a little bit I think
they will I mean you got characters on
both sides a large chunk of protagonist
but a large chunk of antagonist as well
like the whole action hero cliche hitman
or in this case like black-market
mercenary type of individual having to
rescue take care of a child and keep him
keep him safe in the midst of chaos and
bullets flying everywhere it's certainly
a trope but I their line in there about
is such a fast line in there that he had
about Chris Hemsworth had a kid and he
lost his kid or something he couldn't
save him a Hertz unlike generic line
there I'm not sure if I caught that or
if that move my mind isn't as leading me
here no I can see it though maybe there
maybe the boy will become his surrogate
son well that's what it looks like that
he's doing why he probably feels like he
has to take care of him and why he has
to keep him safe it's it's become more
than just the mission at hand he lost
his own kid in this exact situation a
different country admittedly I was a
little bit thrown off I thought this
would be a goofy ass movie from the
opening beer water meditation look over
the way the trailer it cuts it it looked
like he went cliff diving it was a CGI
cliff jump and then he led it it's a
meditation oh this is the movie a
relaxed version of a superhero landing
yeah that's gonna look like the rest of
the chair would just Harbor serious very
ground bigger bird Paul Greengrass style
Gareth Edwards type of action style okay
you know are you guys looking forward to
this movie do you think it's gonna be by
out us leave your thoughts down below we
successfully managed to do this without
making a single Thor reference thank God
Anthony and Joe Russo have directed a
great movie here yeah when everyone's
gonna say they're not gonna realize
they're only the producers this will be
known as their movie it's gonna be a
dark world when they get all that credit
for somebody else's hard that's true and
it's adapted from a graphic novel
they just can't leave the comic book
landscape behind well subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
about last but not least it's in this
with a
Niraj Krishnan well Niraj it's time to
tell you a story oh boy and we're gonna
do a one word at a time let's do this
Niraj Niraj was a big guy and had too
many excuses for his lack of genitalia
so he headed to a doctor's office and
inquired about penile procedures in
death information was abundant and he
said oh let's do it wait for me to pick
money from the money like you say wait
because I was switching characters and
the doctor was gonna say something but
you know this game make it clear and
then neurons got a procedure now he has
three testicles
end of story that's right twist twist
ending Suraj sorry about that hurry
buddy see you buddy